All you have to do is to look at a newborn child and watch their eyes move around.
We want to see, to explore.
We, as human beings, we need that.
I wasn't one of those absolute naturals,...
...but since childhood I've seen pictures of the great explorers...
...and I felt that I'd like to plant the flag.
The three of us, we were weary fiery people.
The bug was on our back to perform.
We really had, with the backpacks, what we needed to survive.
There's a little bit of danger in the unknown.
But human beings, I find, are just not apt to back away from something that is a challenge.
Took eight days altogether.
Yeah, we barely made it, but we did make it.
We were pushing the limits pretty close.
Feelings are not something that we have recorders for.
People will always have a desire to explore what they haven't seen:...
...whether it's above us, on the surface or down in the depths of the ocean.
We feel that this stands as a symbol...
...of the insatiable curiosity of all mankind to explore the unknown.